إنه حقًا غير ملوث ، نحن إلى حد كبير
المكان الوحيد الذي يمكنك الذهاب إليه
للتزلج في حديقة وطنية وهذا
ما يجعله مميزًا حقًا ، هل أنت
اليوم
رائع ، شكرًا لك أو اشترى أبي
منتجعًا في عام 1981 ، لذلك تأمل في
بناء شيء  المصاعد الأولى على
الجبل
ظنوا في الواقع أن الرعب
هناك ولدت
[موسيقى]
بالنسبة لي هذا هو مكاني السعيد إنه في
دمي إنه جزء مني وهو المكان الذي
أشعر فيه بالسعادة على وجه الأرض ولم
يتغير الكثير منذ ذلك الحين  السبعينيات ، يمكننا التأكد من
أننا نظل صادقين مع جذورنا ،
هل يمكنني مسح أي شيء لك ، هل أنت
بخير الآن ، حسنًا ، لا توجد مشكلة ، لذا ما
أود فعله قبل يوم عائلي ، نعم ، هو مجرد
إعداد قائمة ربما بالفعل
العناصر التي تحتاج إلى الاهتمام
[الموسيقى]
بالتأكيد لا يخلو من التحديات في أن تكون
في شركة عائلية ولكن كيف
لا تريد هذا المكان الجميل كمكتب لك ،
نحن فقط نطور هذا
الشغف به منذ سن مبكرة ولا
أتخيل أن أكون في أي مكان آخر
نحن  كلاهما كان له وظائف قبل  لقد جئنا
للعمل هنا في ذلك الوقت وهناك
شيء ما حول هذا المكان
يجذبك إلى الوراء ولذا عندما
أتيحت الفرصة للعودة
والانضمام إلى العمل على أساس التفرغ الكامل ،
قفزنا إليه لأنه في مكان
ما  نحن نحب
[الموسيقى]
إنه لمن الرائع حقًا أن تكون قادرًا على
الهروب من كل
ضغوطك وكل ما يقلقك في كل مكان هو مجرد هذه
الطبيعة البكر الرائعة والجميلة
ونحن نكبر معها وستتم
حمايتها على هذا النحو طوال الوقت
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
أنت